because of the strange life that we have
been thrown into after uh leaving our
positions as college professors
we are reasonably we are pretty well
insulated compared to most people to
various kinds of mandates right because
you know
we run our own business out of our own
home we don't interact with as many
systems that are capable of inflicting
penalties on us but we've in fact run
into penalties twice this week and i'm
not going to talk about the particular
details of the organizations in question
[Music]
but twice we have encountered
discrimination based on
a an unwillingness to receive these
vaccines
and no alternative is offered right it
is not that they are saying
um you can't participate unless you
provide evidence that you don't have
covid with a recent test which frankly i
think is probably unnecessary given
where we are with covid but i'd be
willing to do that right you know
because we are not indifferent to other
people's health and because covet is a
serious disease i wish i thought it was
a
truthful and accurate indicator
um but given that i don't believe that
of the vaccines anyway if you know if
we're in that landscape at least at
least having that be an option
right would be
would be a way to allow
all human beings to participate in
whatever it is that we're trying to
participate in not even just allow my
suspicion based on everything you and i
have uncovered and looked into is that a
person who has a negative test
especially in fact in light of the fact
that the tests seem to be biased in the
direction of uh diagnosing covid where
it might not be they tend more towards
false positives right
that's what you're saying yes
my suspicion is that a person who has a
recent negative test
is safer to be around from the point of
view of the likelihood of catching covet
from them than somebody who's been
vaccinated
a month or two ago
who could very well have coveted and you
wouldn't know
um so the point is if you're really
trying to protect your event
from kovid and i understand certainly
even if you didn't believe in these
vaccines as being safe and effective um
i can certainly imagine being in the
position of hosting an event and
imagining that somebody's going to come
through the door
and you know there might be an event
where people get coveted at your you
know at the thing that you're hosting
and you know
obviously there are consequences there
could be legal consequences why weren't
you vigilant about blah blah blah you
know and there could be uh
you know social damage to your
organization's reputation so i'm
sympathetic and that's why i'm willing
at my own expense to get tested to
participate but what i'm not willing to
do
is pretend that it is acceptable for us
to be othering each other over
[Music]
these remedies
these remedies are not high quality and
they're dangerous and there is no nuance
whatsoever being offered with them so
the idea you know that an organization
would say well you're not vaccinated you
can't participate when they didn't even
ask us if we'd had coveted
right so if we had had covid and hadn't
had a vaccine we would be the safest
people to be around at least as far as
delta goes um so the fact they didn't
ask means that this isn't really about
health in the first place or it's so
unnuanced us to be absurd
and so
enough we cannot continue othering each
other and that means
effectively note that you are being used
by something that hasn't even figured
out if it is interested in health at all
it hasn't even figured out how to aid
stratify or how to separate out those
who are immune from a natural source
versus a vaccine source it hasn't done
any of this work right and it has you
othering other people that's an immoral
entity and so the point is we have to
start turning the heat up on those who
would do the bidding of of this thing
yes
yes and i actually saw um
we also saw
an example online this this wasn't this
didn't directly affect us um but there
are some cities uh now that actually
have vaccine mandates for indoor dining
seattle is one of them
uh we were looking uh to eat at a place
not in seattle
where there are not mandates handed down
from the authorities but where some
cities some institutions like
restaurants do have um vaccine mandates
most of them also say negative tests
within some number of hours at the door
but most most do not and i was looking
at a restaurant that looked really
fabulous and they had all these great
reviews except um
except somehow the overall review
uh
average was very low and it was about
the three most recent reviews who were
all from it turns out members of the
same party had gone into the to the same
to the same meal and at first i thought
oh you know restaurant was having an off
night or something well it turns out
upon reading these reviews
that the major objection that the people
in this party had was that they went out
for some you know big event there were
many of them that went out to this meal
and that this restaurant did not require
proof of vaccination
and that on that basis these three
individuals who had what sounds like a
very good meal
were effectively trying to engaging in
the very same tactics as cancel culture
they they had the ability given that
this is
a restaurant that has not been in
existence for a lot of time and so
didn't have
so many reviews that the three most
recent ones being terrible didn't affect
the overall rankings um they had a
chance and especially in an era of you
know restaurants struggling to survive
and not being clear you know how what
they're going to be required to do by
the city or the state or whatever
um it was particularly appalling that
people would go after a restaurant this
way for
failing to
put up a a
should be their choice vaccine mandate
for entry into their restaurant when
again
cobit is not the only risk to you out
there guys and for almost everyone it is
not the major risk to you by a long shot
and in and again i'm not going to use
the specifics here but the restaurant
owner or um or his agent um responded to
the lengthiest of these galling reviews
and said we're very sorry about these
other experiences uh that you had but
with regard to vaccine mandates uh this
is our choice we choose not to require
evidence of vaccination against covet at
the door
i was about to say he did not say like
nor do we require evidence of
vaccination against rabies at the door
right um and you know most people are
never going to run into rabies you and i
are vaccinated against rabies because we
once lived a life in which we were being
exposed potentially to rabies with some
regularity and and that vaccine was time
tested and understood to be effective as
well
so the owner stood up for himself and as
far as i can tell from the website
they're doing a brisk business still and
actually
actually doing it despite
the techniques
of frankly the the woke ideologues the
the the religious like people who would
have us believe
that all white people are racists and um
you can be a man if you say you're a man
or a woman if you say you're a woman and
um that all sexual assault is equivalent
and all of the other garbage is coming
out of sort of social justice ideology
um
those tactics cancel culture tactics are
now here over in um we found the next
enemy and uh it's it's you it's you're
dirty you're mean you're disrespectful
your heinous your evil if you're
unvaccinated you me you
if if if you are unvaccinated you're the
enemy and therefore
all rules are off the table i can do
whatever i want in order to get you
canceled and in this case a restaurant
that simply doesn't mandate that you as
an unvaccinated person are excluded yeah
it uh effectively treats being
unvaccinated with these vaccines as
synonymous with being diseased and
contagious yes and that is preposterous
if these vaccines worked that would be
preposterous but these vaccines do not
and gibraltar for example tells you that
their fantasy world in which everybody
gets vaccinated and coveted goes away
does not exist right right so they don't
have the right to do this to us and so
the question is
if i was running a business
frankly we see signs on doors that say
you know masks required and all i'm
increasingly annoyed by those signs i
don't know the extent to which those
signs are mandated versus voluntary in
in oregon it's mandated by our governor
right now the question then is can
somebody who is enlightened who
understands the reality of masks that
this is not an n95 mask mandate nor is
this a you know mask mandate that
correctly parses the difference between
putting a mask on a sick person and
putting a mask on a person who
shows no signs of being sick versus the
absurdity of putting a mask on somebody
who's had coveted and recovered and
therefore is really unlikely to transmit
the disease maybe at the level of zero
likelihood
right
so what the question is maybe you know
if i ran a business and i had to put
that sign in my door
what else would i put on my door to
indicate that i was actually aware of
the absurdity of this and that the real
purpose was you know it's some variation
on
uh the don't hurt me wall yes right you
know the the wall of signs that say
black lives matter was not about
somebody emphasizing by repeating it
that black lives matter was about
somebody broadcasting something about
their own you know compliance
and this is likewise not so dissimilar
from the videos that we saw of people
being harassed while dining right you
know put up your fist and say black
lives matter or we'll harass you on
video and broadcast it to the internet
right right the question is oh you know
can you dine here well are you
vaccinated you know are you willing to
say that black lives matter on video
it's all the same thing what will they
put up with what would everyone put up
with how to what degree well what
percentage of the population put up with
this how about this how about this now
we know right what then happens and it
it is effectively like well
we the agents of the narrative have the
right to demand that you indicate that
you are compliant with the narrative and
at the point you indicate you aren't
compliant with the narrative then we
have the right to stigmatize you
right and that is now happening it's not
exactly like it went down with woke and
blm but it's not so different either
it's clearly a variation on the same
playbook and you know this fits very
well with what we've been saying about
you know there's woke original flavor
woke and then there's medical woke right
and the point is these have nothing to
do
with
science or a detailed analysis that
reveals a pattern that these are
narrative assertions that then cause
citizens
to step in and do what government cannot
right citizens are being used against
each other and it is very much you know
is it exactly brown shirts no but the
problem is
you know why are we in that quadrant of
the library why are we searching for
analogies in that quadrant of the
library that should be telling you
something right that should be telling
you something and so the point is you
know what it's not brown shirts but
it's not so different either right it's
not tuskegee
but it's not so different either right
there are genuine real analogies to be
drawn here and the fact is that you know
exactly put up the uh
image i sent you
this is effectively what they're doing
to us right this iconic image of
separate drinking fountains
right we are being told that the world
has to break down this way and frankly i
don't know this is obviously way before
our time i don't know what the official
rational rationalization was for
separate drinking fountains i it
certainly has an epidemiological
implication right which is of course
obviously stupid and absurd it's not
like people within a race don't give
each other diseases right so this was
obviously a phony implication these
drinking fountains needed to be
separated and it's not so different well
yeah i mean i think the rhetoric like
now was around um dirtiness and lesser
status
and lesser worth yeah yeah it is and you
know enough so what i hope you know
there
obviously our core audience is not uh
new to the idea that something wrong is
afoot and that the narrative is taking
liberties it has no right to take and it
isn't based in science but for those who
are maybe encountering us early or
beginning to wake up to the idea that
they've been dragged into something that
isn't what they were told
please think about the degree to which
you are being used to do the bidding of
a government that can't do this itself
it needs your help to stigmatize other
citizens and the first thing to do is to
stop complying
[Music]
you